[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
wollen einfach ein bisschen gerichten
was wir die letzten wochen erlebt haben
und jetzt die woche erlebt haben wie es
vielleicht schon mitbekommen habt hat
sally oder das gesamte team wir haben
die goldene kamera gewonnen in berlin
ja es war nicht der wahnsinn was wir in
diesen fünf tagen das war letzte woche
montag angefangen eine richtig coole
story
wir waren am montag schon in berlin
genau am montagabend
und da hat in berlin das neue youtube
space germany aufgemacht und zwar news
pace germany das ist dass google
headquarter richtig ob englisch genau
richtig mein englisch wars kid und da
hat die sally am montag und am dienstag
dass das youtube space eröffnet das
youtube space ist es ist ein ort der von
google geschaffen wurde für juni creator
richtig also nicht in vielen creator
also youtuber genau wo genau wo junge
youtuber die mindestens 10.000
abonnenten haben dort ihre videos
kostenlos drehen genau das heißt er ist
dann dafür einfach online so einen
fragebogen ausfüllen also euch online
registrieren
und alle youtube ab 10.000 abonnenten es
gibt auch ausnahmen da dürfen auch
kleinere rein genau können dort ihre
videos kostenlos produzieren
[Musik]
zum job geworden sich jeder habe ich ein
unternehmen aufzubauen
zu schaffen mitarbeiter einzustellen ein
jahr halten momentan etwa 50 mitarbeiter
und drei
europas erfolgreichste counter youtube
mit 1,5 millionen abonnenten nicht
täusche 400 millionen abrufen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der ascheberger
durchführen
was
[Musik]
so werden noch vermisst
haben etwas zu sagen genau hier wird
weiter gearbeitet heute montag das sind
alles schon wieder dran
ja und das backbuch weiter und das cool
ist seit youtube gemacht für leute die
man coole projekte machen möchten und
richtig hochwertiges equipment brauchen
kann man sich da alles kostenlos leihen
die genial ist filmemachen auf ihr altes
team kost über 50.000 hat er gerade
gesagt und das ding ist rollbar so etwas
50.000 euro kosten rollbar ist da kann
es auch mitnehmen wirklich richtig
manches verlieren auch wenn die kleine
morath mit dieser kamera heraus rennt
neue space wurde jetzt in berlin
eröffnet und die sally duft des zusammen
mit john mayer zusammen eröffnen
da war dann die ganze politprominenz da
waren leute aus der wirtschaft dar
und die haben sich ja alles angehört was
eine youtube genau ist mein youtube ist
inzwischen riesen bestandteil jeder
verbringt täglich ungefähr 33 minuten
auf youtube kein spaß jetzt wirklich und
youtube wird auch immer christian
irgendwann wird youtube uns alle
ersetzen
da gibt es auf youtube schon niemand
mehr an eine richtig coole plattform und
da haben wir die öffnung gemacht dann
hat sally zb mit sturm waffe vielleicht
kennt ihr denn ampullen youtube-kanal
macht schule kochen backen videos hatte
ursprünglich angefangen mit lätz place
also nicht so gaming macht coole videos
auch kuchen backt videos mit ihm dürften
wir das studio auch einmal dann kannte
und eier zwei richtig coole kreative
leute filmemacher gehen haben wir auch
ein koch und back video gedreht und
bosch mit denen wir zusammenarbeiten das
bisher inzwischen bosch hat eine küche
hingestellt innerhalb von zwei tagen mit
eine coole show küche wo man coole
videos drehen konnten
diese küche ist eigentlich auf der ifa
bei bosch gestanden und bosch war so
cool sagt hey wir haben youtube space
eröffnung in berlin
wir brauchen die küche wenn man ein paar
coolen creator videos machen möchten und
die haben sie hauptsächlich stellen und
die küche
nach dem direkt hier in berlin auch und
es ist jetzt auch und hier seht ihr
natürlich die ganze küche und wir haben
leider kein waschbecken habe ich recht
und da gibt's doch kisten schleppen muss
ja kistenschleppen immer ich weil ich
stärksten habe ich mich hat die kiste
gefunden
hier ist noch mal eine kiste und jetzt
ja auf jeden fall haben wir wirklich die
queen hat roche verfügung gestellt
richtig coole geschichte und wir haben
unser ganzes zeug auswahl mitgebracht
weil gekommen von politprominenz
wirtschaftsprominenz coole creator kommt
noch eine ganze zeit gewünscht haben
auch ganz auf das irgendwo vielleicht
noch in einer drinsteht habe ich mir
nicht gewünscht sei
übrigens ist marco marco arbeitet hier
für den getränke dienst und und bringt
auch die kiste um alles genau
ja und ja und jetzt wo alles herrichten
hinrichten lassen morgen drehen können
du bist ganz schön groß geld für die
frau würde ich sagen ich habe extra
große schuhe gekauft und zwar daher
selten
ich hatte übrigens mal ich weiß schon
erzählt habe habe kumpel heißt schavan
und zum schavan als die 18 firma zu
haben beide 18
ich weiß aber nicht nach namen oder nein
aber nach meiner sicht gesehen und
damals gesagt der zuschauer
ich möchte eines tages eine frau
heiraten die größer und schlauer ist als
ich einfach so wild ist einfach so da
hat sie mir gesagt größe ist kein
problem wohl aber sobald die frau
schlauer ist als du bist nicht mehr
genau so hier haben wir übrigens den
kühlschrank
den gibt es nicht zu kaufen das ist eine
wechselgrund was aber noch immer schon
haben ja nie gezeigt und zwar hier
dieses sie sich und zwar es ist wirklich
das ist der bahn es gibt es noch gar
nichts aber es kommt bald und zwar ist
es dass männer besser wenn ein messer
das sind sie auch dass granja messer und
zwar die sms zum fleisch klein zu hacken
gemüse kann auch ist es nie gemessen und
es ist auch eine richtig coole sachen
leder vegan nicht vorher und auch nicht
nachher also auch richtig gut
und zwar das zeichnet ganz kurz dann
gehst du auf menü dann drückst du auf es
ist jetzt kannst du hier zum beispiel
kuchen pizza co irgendwas eintrag ich
sage einfach noch fleisch wenn ich kein
fleisch esse sorgen dann drücke ich
immer rindfleisch will ich gerne fleisch
esse so und jetzt
dann drücke ich viele weil ich ganz
viele äste und zwar das medium dann tue
ich hier auf viele medium dann drücke
ich drauf und dann kann ich hier die
ganz einstellen und zwar sage ich zum
beispiel 1000 gramm je 1000 cups sind
nach adam riese ein kilogramm auf jeden
fall
dann drückt sie nur start unserer
schönen stadt zack und normalerweise
etwas drin und innerhalb von ein paar
minuten kommt dass viele fertig raus
medium richtig fahren sehen
es ist funktion dann was haben wir noch
eine kaffeemaschine
da ist noch ein kaffee drohen deswegen
und die haben auch das ganze klimbim und
jetzt kannst du dir jetzt noch irgendwie
ein
ja das war es jetzt hier von der
rundfunk habe ich jetzt mal eine küche
zeit noch ein paar sachen zeigt hier
sind wir geschafft das kommt auch um
bald hier ist ein topf karotte
so jetzt mal ein küchentuch hätten und
dafür ist es youtube studios studio da
dass man sich mit kreativen austausch
gemeinsamkeiten finden und vielleicht
coole videos produziert das haben wir
die ersten zwei tage im youtube space in
berlin gemacht und dann ging es
eigentlich auf die goldene kamera
verleihung im kraftwerk das war ein
youtube band aber auch event von der
funke media zu den goldenen kamera
digital award wir waren letztes jahr
schon nominiert
danke sally ja wahnsinn
auch wir können wollte ich kenne ihn
nicht und meine frau ist es youtube die
macht koch videos haben letztes jahr
leider nicht gewonnen da waren mit ganz
ganz tolle andere da ist auch wirklich
verdient hatten und dieses jahr ging
wie soll ich sagen golden der kamera
award ging an die sally oder an unser
team und unser gesamtes team und haben
das ding nach waghäusel gebracht also
richtig cool so was in waghäusel zu
haben ist eine unglaubliche bereicherung
auch für uns und unglaubliche
auszeichnung gesorgt
wir sind jetzt in berlin in der welt der
schönen und reichen und zwar ab heute
hier die youtube award statt die goldene
kamera und allem drum und dran das ist
ihr seht mich jetzt mental auf dem roten
teppich ist richter wahnsinn und hier
werden nachher die ganzen ganzen die
ganzen reichen leute reinkommen und
allem drum und dran
und hier werden die ganzen celebrities
reinlaufen das sind wir natürlich nicht
wir haben einen gesonderten eingang und
den gesunden eigenwillig mal ganz eigen
also visavis kommen hier rein und wir
kommen hier ist der eingang für für mich
und viele gehen hier okay war fotos von
ok
jetzt haben wir gleich so ein panel
nennt sich das so mastermind und zwar
erzählen wir master blaster master class
ist master class ist schon kenne
ruhig aber mir einfach über die
entstehungsgeschichte des ellis welt
erzählen
es sind viele leute von youtube google
diverse unternehmen und da ist eben
einfach was wir gemacht haben dass wir
so sind so haben einiges gemacht
eigentlich nur so geblieben wie wir sind
und dass er zehnmal nicht und will alles
entstanden ist was uns immer wichtig war
und das ist nicht so ein event kommen
jetzt erzählte scheckkarten schaffte ist
und wenn du jeden tag morgens aufstehst
und arbeitest und das macht das macht so
was machen wir nicht wir hatten einfach
die geschichte
[Musik]
ich bin nur
und
was sie gemeint
[Applaus]
[Musik]
der wert entspricht dann gibt es auf den
punkt
wien
auf dem kanal ok
[Musik]
[Applaus]
herr luft mächtigen baum eintritt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
leichter ist als wasser
[Musik]
im inland
wir haben vielleicht mehr
[Musik]
[Applaus]
an
eigentlich und habe sich dann in der 3
aufgegeben
in seiner arbeit haben finden
[Musik]
von wieland
sprechen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wir haben tolle tolle leute
kennengelernt auf der ganzen
veranstaltung vom film fernsehen
wirtschaft politik tolle creator mein
persönliches highlight war eigentlich
muss ich erzählen bei der verleihung
sondern da geht es dann wieder sally
ganz vorne und vor uns hat auf der bühne
haben die fantastischen vier performt
und irgendwann nachdem ich mir formt
hatten sie es zurück zur veranstaltung
haben sich hinter uns gesessen gesetzt
und plötzlich hat dann das motto
vielleicht kennt denn jemand das wunder
hat mir an die schulter geklopft und hat
dann gesagt helmrath wir feiern euch so
wir machen daheim alle rezepte nach
können wir nachher zusammen foto machen
und ich bin ein unglaublicher fanta vier
fällen immer ein unglaublich tolle
müssen sie machen ich weiß nicht wie es
denn um das rap hiphop oder pop nennt
ich weiß es tut mir leid wenn ich der
falsche ausdruck
aber seit jahren verfolge ich die die
haben 30 jähriges bühnenjubiläum gehabt
und ist das motto kommt und sagt komm
lass uns nach einem foto zusammen machen
und der feiert das richtig und als
nachher verformt hat ist er auf die
bühne hatten hat den song gespielt hat
die sally erwähnt es war richtig
wahnsinnig das war mein persönliches
highlight die musik diese machen es
weder beleidigend beleidigen niemand da
wird keine mutter beleidigt kein puder
beleidigt oder irgendwas sie kommen auch
nicht auch auf sie kommen auch nicht aus
dem ghetto oder sowas aber die musik
muss ich von der kontaktstelle musik
anhört aber ich immer eine gute laune
ich kenne doch titel wie ein tag am meer
die da ist ein ganz cooler titel oder
mfg und das war wirklich wahnsinn ihn
auch da kennen zu lernen wir haben
weitere stars kennengelernt war einfach
für uns aus dem dorf aus waghäusel eine
wahnsinnige geschichte nachher auch auf
der bühne zu sehen
meine frau jetzt auch wirklich verdient
muss man sagen andere ins auch verdient
aber wir haben wir nicht darauf
hingefiebert das ist irgendwann klappt
und jetzt ist er da und
wahnsinnige preis und war auf jeden fall
eine gigantische veranstaltung mit ganz
ganz tollen menschen und für uns aus und
dort wie gesagt eine unglaubliche
geschichte wie wir diese geschichte
jetzt weiter spielen weiß ich nicht
möglich ist was anderes überlegen für
nächste woche was mir die beiden wieder
starten lassen oder ja genau und jetzt
arbeiten wir weiter man ruht sich nicht
auf seinen lorbeeren aus sondern macht
immer weiter schon langsam spaß macht
das ist es wichtig ist das ist ein spaß
macht und das macht es uns definitiv und
meine frau ist dahin schon wieder am
backen und am kochen und ich mich bei
euch allen bedanken für die
unterstützung für die ganz coolen unter
vielen e mail zugeschickt hat und die
glückwünsche war eine unglaubliche
erfahrung für uns das gegen die türkei
die türkischen zeitung malz drin und
haben sich unsere verwandten bei uns
gemeldet das war wirklich wahnsinn und
heute morgen schon mal das war erst am
freitag und heute morgen waren schon
briefe drin von politikern aus der
region die uns unsere glückwünsche
geschickt haben dass es wahnsinnig ist
auch für die region
es war auch bei uns ihr wisst gar nicht
wie dass sie uns für uns ist in
waghäusel das ist so ein kleines nest
und so etwas großes zu erreichen und so
was cooles zu machen ist er wieder 40
zentimeter werden
ok auf jeden fall noch mal 1000 tausend
dank für alles die jury die für uns
geworden genau danke eine jury du weißt
du warum mir der preis so besonders war
weil aus gold ist nein wird okay weil
alle anderen preise die wir gekriegt
haben
die meisten gingen hals immer um das um
das thema food also es war immer so
irgendwie eine kategorie tote und jetzt
bin ich in der kategorie rettung wir als
eltern schon und coaching und das finde
ich richtig cool weil ich meine da gibt
es halt ganz viele bereiche auf youtube
gibt's von der benjamin herausgeber auch
nominiert mega genau gucken sie mal an
der macht zu foto tutorials ja dass auch
die laura die auch nominiert laura kam
genau macht auch krasse tutorials
deswegen fand ich dann als zweiter auch
verdient und deswegen kann ich die
auszeichnung aber benjamin wir sehen uns
bei mir in der küche das coole band
genau das coole warm ist eine ganz kurze
geschichten ist wieder dort nicht zu
lange ja ich war die tanzfläche und da
kommt ein freund von uns von prosieben
prosiebensat 1 die johannes kommt zu mir
da kommt johannes zu mir und war ein
bisschen betrübt ich habe seit johannes
was ist los bei dir da sagte johannes
blum morath ich habe gerade 50 euro man
tischtennis verlorene tischtennis sagt
ja dass ardian das war johannes sagt
johannes jakob unten im foyer stehle
tischtennisplatte und da ist so ein
junge der hat mich abgezockt und ich
habe da 50 euro verloren und das wissen
das lustige ist dass ich jetzt ohne spaß
meine frau kann es bezeugen
ich habe meinem leben noch nie einen
tisch verloren mit ich habe noch nie in
meinem leben das verloren dann hast du
johannes gesagt herr johannes hat so ich
wollte die 50 euro wieder zurück so man
hat alles wie machst du das sagt bring
mich zu dem jungen ich mache ihn kaputt
und diese junge das war moritz guard
kennt ihr denn da machst du denn hier
hatten lied gemacht das nennt sich
bumerang und er ist momentan auch
richtig geheim ist ein ganz ganz tolles
senkt und damit zu dem ich sehr komisch
angeschaut und habe ich noch richtig
kaputtgemacht also ich habe nicht
besiegen immer alles so genau
und dann habe ich hier mit 21 zu 8
abgezockt habe die 50 euro wieder
zurückgeholt und seitdem ist johannes
may manager also wer jemals mal ein
spiegel mich spiel möchte im tischtennis
ich mach ich fertig aber nicht mehr
zeigen er hat echt noch nie verloren ich
sehe zwar nicht als sie zwar nicht
sportlich aus aber im tischtennis
schlägt mich wahrscheinlich keiner
es ist auch eine aufforderung an timo
boll den deutschen meister der
siebenfachen achtfachen deutschen
meister
lieber timo ich mach dich fertig ok
alles da also ganz ganz liebe grüße aus
waghäusel noch mal tausend dank für
alles 1000 youtube tausend dank an alle
an seine eltern an unsere eltern an
meine eltern und dann kann ich das thema
fleißig einschaltet genau
liebe grüße ans finanzamt bruchsal das
dings nicht aus gold
muss nicht versteuert werden ist nur
metall vergoldet ansonsten im jahr
darauf nochmals über die
zulassungsstelle in bruchsal sagen und
meinen könnte wissen schneller gehen ok
ok raschen abschluss
vielen dank für alles ist ein buch
fertig genau und folgt mir auf dienstag
im eigenen kanal der murat tischtennis
gott außer gott das ist bleibt noch ganz
gut macht kann man nicht aus ich habe es
lima nie kennengelernt
liefertermin cooler typ war lustig mit
ihr zu reden wollen der richtig lustig
hat spaß gemacht und ich hoffe wir
backen mal zusammen du und ich zeige dir
mal macarons management stellen ist aber
dann finde ich nicht okay
tschüs habt ihr noch marco kniest marco
mach es auch gut marco ganz cooler typ
andreas briese auch noch mein gott
andreas youtube-chef deutschland und
philipp used to was machte philipp ist
europachef kugel genau youtube google
alles philipp macht alles okay
und jetzt
darüber denkt jetzt 123
es geht nicht mal handy geht nicht meine
handy hängt ja ach komm nimmst du ja
auch mit ja und natürlich darf ich kurz
übergeben noch am handy nächstes nur ich
weiß nicht was das eingestehen
bitte herr zu sein